بده يقول الله
تعالى في الايه السادسه
والسابعه من سوره الرعد
ويستعجلونك بالسيئه قبل الحسنه وقد خلت من
قبلهم المثولات
وان ربك لذو مغفره للناس على ظلمهم وان
ربك لشديد
العقاب
ويقول الذين كفروا لولا انزل عليه ايه من
ربه انما انت منذر ولكل قوم
هاد يقول تعالى ويستعجلونك بالسيئه قبل
الحسنه
ويستعجلونك
بالسيئه بما
يسوءهم قبل الحسن
قبل
الخير وذلك انهم كانوا ياتون اليه
استهزاء عليه الصلاه
والسلام
ف
يتحدون
يقولون فلتسقط السماء علينا كسفا كما
زعمت اجعل السماء
تمطر حجاره على رؤوسنا انزل علينا حجاره
من من السماء ائتنا بعذاب اليم فليقم ربك
الساعه الان ان كنت صادقا وامثال هذه
الاقوال
الجاهله ونسال الله ونسال الله العافيه
وهذا يدل
على
عظيم صبر الله سبحانه وتعالى وحلم
الله وقد جاء في
الصحيحين
في صحيحي البخاري
ومسلم ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول لا احد اصبر على اذى سمعه من الله
تعالى ينسبون اليه
الولد
و
يرزقهم
ويعافيهم سبحانه
وتعالى
هم يؤذون الله والاذيه غير
الضرر الضرر لا
يمكن للعبد ان يضر الله سبحانه
وتعالى لكن
الاذيه ان الذين يؤذون الله
ورسوله فهذه الاذيه الله سبحانه وتعالى
على
غيرته وعلى
انتقامه وعلى غضبه سبحانه
وتعالى الا انه قال ان رحمتي سبقت
غضبي ولو اخذ الله سبحانه
وتعالى كل احد
بكل ما
يفعل وعاجل كل من عصاه فانه لا يترك على
الارض من دابه ابدا من دابه ليس من انسان
من دابه لان
الدواب يحصل منها الظلم وان لم يكن لها
النيه نيه الظلم مش موجوده ما عندها
نيه لكن يحصل
الظلم لذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول
ان يقول في صحيح مسلم حديث ابن عمر بان
المظالم ترد الى اهلها يوم القيامه حتى
يقاد الشات الجلحاء من الشه
القرناء الشاه اللي لها قرون نطحت شاه
جلحاء فانها تقتص منها يوم القيامه لكن
هذا الاقتصاص هذا الظلم الذي يحدث ليس
عليه السيئه والحسنه ما في ما في نيه
معقوده والنيه
والعلم شرطان في
العقوبه وايضا في في في
الجزاء فال الدواب ليست لها
نيات لكن يحدث منها الظلم لذلك الله
سبحانه
وتعالى قض بينها يوم القيامه واذا الوحوش
حشرت يقول
سبحانه فعلى كل حال الله سبحانه وتعالى
يحلم
عنهم ينسبون اليه
الولد وينسبون
اليه سبحانه وتعالى الشريك ولا يزالوا
يرزقهم
ويعافيهم
يقول تعالى
ويستعجلونك بالسيئه قبل الحسنه لو كان
عندهم وهذا دليل على النيه الفاسده لو
كانت لهم نيه
صالحه
لقالوا قولا غير الذي يقولون لما قالوا
فل تاتي بعذاب من عند الله فلته لكنا
فلتقم الساعه ان كما زعمت لا لكان
قولهم
فل يهدني ربك ان كنت
صادقا
فليهدنى
اليه
واجعلنا هداه مهديين هذا هو دعاء الذي له
نيه صالحه لكن نياتهم معقوده على الكفر
ليس بناء على البرهان
والعلم
بل هذه النيه معقوده سابقا قبل الايات
سابقا
على معقوده على الكفر بناء على
الهوى ومن اضل ممن اتبع هواه بغير هدى من
الله
فالذي ينوي الكفر قبل مجيء الدليل فاي
دليل
ينفعه لذلك يقول
تعالى في عده
ايات ما
مفاده لو جاءتهم كل ايه لا
يؤمنون حتى يروا والعذاب
الاليم لماذا يؤمنون
عند ملاقاه
العذاب السبب لان الدافع لهم على الكفر
الهوى واذا ما كانوا في الالم
فهوا يملي عليهم الايمان
حينئذ فهؤلاء ليس يحكمهم العقل ولا
الدليل وليس لهم
شيء من النيه
الصالحه وانما
معقوده نياتهم على
الفساد لذلك يقول ويستعجلونك بالسيئه قبل
الحسنه وقد خلت من قبلهم المثولات
المثولات جمع
مثله على وزن
سمره
والمثل العذاب
المثله العقوبه في لغه
العرب وهي ماخوذه من ماده الميم والثاء
واللام وهي تدل على
التشويه يقول يقال مثل فلان بفلان اي مثل
به يعني بجثمانه بعد
موته فقوله تعالى المثلات جمع
مثله وهي العقوبه التي تؤثر
تاثيرا
لا
يزول بعده من
العقوبه يقع بهم العقوبه التي
تشوهه هذه هي المثولات
والله عز وجل يقول وقد خلت من قبلهم
المثولات ليس هذا صعبا على الله ولا يعصر
وليس على الله بعزيز ولكن رحمه بعباده
سبحانه والله تعالى يقول انهم يرونه بعيدا
ونراه
قريبا الناس نحن ننظر الى
السنوات العشر سنين ال سنه ال 50 سنه
نراها كانها كثيره بعيده لماذا لاننا
ا
لاننا ناخذ
الزمن لحظه فلحظه لابد ان ياتينا
بالترتيب ليس الامر
كذلك في حق الله سبحانه
وتعالى فانه
ينظر ويرى هذه
الاشياء ويقول سبحانه وتعالى وان يوما عند
ربك كالف سنه مما
تعدون
ولذلك يخطئ بعض الناس يقيس الاخره على
الدنيا فمثلا يسال اسئله تدل على فساد
المبنى فساد الفهم يقول
مثلا
لنفترض عندنا
فرعون اخطا فاهلك الله فقال تعالى النار
يعرضون عليها ماشي فهو يعذب في
قبره وياتي بعد 5000
سنه مثله تماما يفعل مثل ما فعل تماما بل
مما فعل هل يمكن هذا
يمكن ف يهلكه الله
فيدخل في عذاب
القبر فهذا الذي سبق يعذب 5000 سنه زياده
على هذا الذي
لحق وان استويا
في في
الفعل هذا سؤال يسال يساله بعض الناس
وهذا ايش السؤال هذا مبني على ماذا مبني
على
الافتراض ان
الزمن في القبر مثل الزمن في الارض عندنا
هذا
خطا حتى نحن لا نرى
الزمن بنفس
الطريقه الذي يكون في شده يرى الدقيقه
وكانها
ساعه والذي في راحه يرى الدقيقه وكانها
لحظه وكذلك
الدواب النمله
والفراشه وال يا تشعر
بالزمن
ا بطريقه مختلفه تماما لقله العلم وكثره
العلم و الاحوال المحيطه على كل
حال مما اجمع عليه علماء
الاسلام سلفا
وخلفا ونقل هذا الاجماع ابن عبد البر رحمه
الله في كتابه
العلم العلم
وفضله فضل
العلم نقل الاجماع من ائمه
المسلمين على منع جواز ال
القياس في
الغيبيات لا
يجوز ان تقيس في
الغيبيات تقول في الدنيا الامر كذلك اذا
في الاخره الامر كذلك هذا لا يجوز هذه
غيبيات
وكذلك مثل
موضوع عذاب القبر مثلا هذه
غيبيات لا نقيس فيها القياس
ممنوع ممتنع باجماع
العلماء بل جميع ما نعتقده من احوال
الاخره فهي مبنيه على ماذا على النص
الصريح يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول الله نؤمن بما جاءنا على ظاهر معناه
ونتوقف عند ذلك
لا نقيس
فالقياس لا
يجوز في امور
الغيب ويقول ابن عبد البر واجمعوا على
القياس في غير ذلك يعني ان القياس جائز في
غير ذلك ليس كما تقول
الظاهريه فقوله تعالى وقد خلت من قبلهم
المثولات
وثم قراءات متعدده في كلمه
مثولاكس
والمث ثلاثتهن
سبعيه لكن المعنى واحد والمث هي العقوبات
الشديده التي تترك اثر في
المعاقب يقول وان ربك لذو مغفره للناس على
ظلمهم المغفره ما هي
المغفره
المغفره هذه من ماده غفر يغفر او
يغفر غفرانا
وغفرا الغفر في لغه العرب هو
الستر
لذلك
يقال المغفر مغفر الشرطه لانه يستر
ويحمي الشرطه في جواه كذلك مغفر الحرب وهي
البيضه التي يلبسها الفارس او المقاتل على
على
راسه
و
المغفره ان يستر الله سبحانه وتعالى
الانسان
المسيء ان يستره الله وان يحفظه من عواقب
هذا السوء هذه اسمها
مغفره فلما تقول اللهم اغفر لي يعني اللهم
استرني واللهم
احفظني ان
يلحقني شيء من السوء من هذا العمل السيء
الذي اقترفته هذا هو
المغفره فالله سبحانه
وتعالى يقول تعالى وان
ربك لاحظوا ولم يقل ان الله ان ربك ويخاطب
من النبي محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم النبي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
له الرحمه في الدنيا والاخره ام لا نعم
الله يرحمه وقد غفر له وقد ضمن
له
الجنه فماذا يدلنا هذه العلاقه هذه النسبه
وان
ربك هذا يعني
ماذا ان اتباع النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يضمن للانسان
المغفره لان الله تعالى يغفر للنبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم فلاحظوا الكلمه ان
ربك وان ربك لذو مغفره
للناس على ظلمهم على هنا بمعنى مع مع
ظلمهم على الرغم من ظلمهم فهو لذو
مغفره وان ربك
مره
اخرى هذا الذي يخاطب هو النبي محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم وان
ربك وهذا يدل على ماذا على ان عصيان النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم فان الله ربه ينتقم له
سبحانه وان ربك لشديد
العقاب
شديد العقاب لكن سبقت رحمته
غضبه جاء في الصحيحين من حديث ابي
هريره ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال لما خلق الله السماوات
والارض كتب في كتاب فهو عنده فوق العرش ان
رحمتي سبقت غضبي
وفي روايه ان رحمتي غلبت
غضبي هذا ليس يعني ان الانسان ليس معرضا
لغضب الله بل يقول تعالى ومن يحلل عليه
غضبي فقد
هوى لكن الاصل ليس الغضب لذلك لا يسمى
الله الغضبان وال
الغضوب لان الغضب فيه شر وفيه خير لا يكون
خيرا الا في
مواضعه وصفات الله تعالى
كلها كلها الغايه في الخير وفي
الحسن وفي العلو فلا يوصف سبحانه وتعالى
الائق واسماؤه حسنى يعني
بالغه الغايه في الحسن فلا يسمى الا بما
كان خيرا
كله يعني مثلا
الكلام
الكلام هل الكلام كله
خير لا في كلام ليس بخير وفي مواضع ليس
بخير هذه المواضع للكلام صح ولا لا
اذا الكلام يوصف الله تعالى به لانه من
الكمال لكن لا يسمى به لا يقال
المتكلم لان الكلام ليس خيرا في جميع
الاحوال كذلك الغضب كذلك المكر كذلك هذه
الاشياء يوصف الله تعالى بها في مواضع
ماذا في مواضع
الكمال واما الاسم فلا يكون له اسم الا ما
كان حسنا الغايه في الحسن
ولله الاسماء
الحسنى اسماء الحسنى جمع
حسناء
وهو البالغ
الغايه في الحسن
والكمال
والمدح يقول تعالى ويقول الذين
كفروا الذين
كفروا هذه السوره
انزلت في مكه اليس
كذلك والذين كفروا من هم هم المشركون اهل
مكه صح ولا
لا اذا هؤلاء اهل مكه ماذا كان
كفرهم كانوا مشركين اليس كذلك يعبدون الله
ويعبدون غيره معه هذا
كفرهم لا ينكرون وجود الله
لا
ينكرون ربوبيه الله بشكل مجمل ثم اشياء
ينكرونها لكن بشكل عام يؤمنون بان الله هو
الرازق وان الله هو الخالق ان الله هو
المدبر لكن
كفروا
كيف كفروا بان اشركوا معه غيره سبحانه
وتعالى وكفروا بان ردوا رساله النبي صلى
الله عليه
وسلم هل كانوا يعلمون انه
نبي نعم يقول تعالى فانهم لا
يكذبونك ولكن الظالمين بايات
الله
يجحدون
ف هم يؤمنون انه نبي بل نقل ابن اسحاق
وعنه ابن
هشام ان ابا
جهل وقف يوم بدر وتب وت
و تبتل ورفع يديه ودعا الله ابو جهل
اه وقال اللهم اقطع
للرحم و
من جاء منا بما
نستغرب
فهزمه
دعا دعا على نفسه قال الله تعالى ان
تستفتحوا فقد جاءكم
الفتح دعوت الله
فاستجاب وروى ابن اسحاق
باسناده
وعنه ابن
هشام في مختصر س
سيرته
يقول ان ابا
جهل قال
لبعض من
معه اننا نعلم انه
نبي ولكن متى
تكون
لبني
هاشم
الفضل ما يكون الفضل لهم احنا كنا
متسابقين معاهم في الجاهليه والان جاءوا
بنبي يوحى اليه من السماء
كيف كيف نتسابق معاهم في هذه لا فقال ابو
جهل والله لا نؤمن به
ابدا فهم ما كانوا ينكرون نبوته هم في
الظاهر ينكرون نبوته
لكن في
الحقيقه واستيقن
بها وجحدوا بها واستيقنتها
انفسهم مثل فرعون مثل جميع هؤلاء لماذا
لان هذا الكتاب لا يمكن للانسان ان يكفر
بان يكفر
بمجيئه من الله وبانه كلام الله
وكذلك
القمر
شق الله سبحانه وتعالى القمر وجعل الحجر
والشجر
تتكلم وجاء بالايات العظيمه كيف ينكرون
ذلك لا يمكن لكن الذي
انعقد انعقدت نيته وعزيمته على الكفر قبل
مجيء الايات
فهذا هذا مهما تاتيه من ايه فانه لن يؤمن
بها يقول وقال ويقول الذين كفروا لولا
انزل عليه ايه من ربه يعني مما يقترحون هم
ائتي بكذا اتي بكذا ائتي
بكذا
ليس من الحكمه ان يستجاب لهم في
ذلك لا نقول فقط ليس مفروضا
على النبي ان ياتي بذلك بل نقول ليس من
الحكمه ان يستجاب لهم في
ذلك انما انت
منذر المنذر من الانذار والانذار هو
الاعلام مع
التخويف انما انت منذر يعني مقيم الحجه
عليهم
تنذرهم ولكل قوم
هاد هاد هنا الاصل
هادي حذفت الياء
تخفيفا ولذلك جاء التنوين ولكل قوم
هاد ولا يقال
هاد لانه صحيح مرفوع لكن هنا بالتنوين
التنوين هنا عوضا عن الياء المحذوفه ان
شاء
الله الى هنا نقف ونكمل غدا والله اعلم
صلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محد yesterday
even in3 chapter سه
الر the chapter regarding the
thunder in ver number
number الله سبحانه
وتالى
صلى الله عليه
وسلم سبحانه وتعالى
trans
and cheng you ‏is b for before cheng you
that is good
for in
spite of the that the punishs of the
prev
nations have come time and time again
before
them what does
me he speaking to the prop الله عليه
وسلم
صلى الله عليه
وسلم a resurrection they
disb in his so the disbeliever
of
‏your
lord drop the sky on us if really a
prophet if really a
messenger then have your lord start
judgment day
now start it
now
‏this line of thinking articulates what
it articulates deficiency in their
in they had the intention
disb no matter what
no
‏knowledge not based upon reason or
objectivity their disbelief is not based
on evidence their disbelief is based on
desire is based
on they decided
befor we will believe no matter what you
bring us ‏matter show us
matter why because we
disagree life we
disagree
قش didn't
all didn't all ex
bel
ابو
لهبي خف he disb because it is bad for
his bu he can't make as much money in
the way of his of his business
ende some
disb
because
of their desire for leadership
قش to
them he's going to be taken our spot now
we're going to be second in command
after this we have to do what he says
after before we were the ones in charge
their desire for leadership their
arrogance
that's ابو جهل
ابو
جهل ابو جهل disb main out
ar
and for the reason of leadership he want
to the leader even
though the صلى الله عليه وسلم never said
i the le now my not said he didn't say
if you believe you be leader any no
‏those who as leers the
prophet عل ifj their
leadership
with with teachings
islam عبد اللهن سول the of
hrit in many years lat heed ofy
‏ibed
jy don't all have the ex
bel
religious
bel some religious
all
but religion is good money for them
can
‏so they have different reasons for
disbelieving but they all
collaborated in their disbelief of the
propet الله عليه
وسلم and so if they proper intention
their intention was pure they would not
even formulate sentences if you're
truly a prophet then tell
your god to to to
‏to destroy us now tell him
to stones on our heads from the heavens
these are things that they would not
even say if they had correct intention
and they honestly were just
confused the kinds of things they would
say would be if you truly a
messenger have your lord guide us have
your make us mus whatever they would
صلى الله عليه وسلم الله سبحانه
وتالى ask you for that which is bad for
them before they ask for that which is
good for
them
and in of this the permanent
‏tak
عا all are
allin the people of
sord
all
‏egy
and d but
ثود مدا
صح
seen was a thriving civil that was here
before us and there not a tr of them
left
‏n
techy
nell where
us
however صلى الله عليه وسلم الله سبحانه
وتعالى
‏for of people in
wring spite of the wrong doing and
indeed your lord is of great
punishment
come har صل الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله عليه
وسلم
‏disb they make a mockery of the propet
صل الله عليه وسلم and his mage and his
followers what prev الله سبحانه وتالى
from destroying them immediately allah
doesn't need them they are in great need
of الله سبحانه وتالى that is that
allah's
mercy sued
‏ang الله سبحانه
وتعالى بخاري ملم هيره صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله wr on ta
and
with ‏above the throne to this day
indeed my mercy sued my anger doesn't
mean that he doesn't have
anger it just means that his
mercy is more likely his mercy
is the ru his anger is the exception
سحانه
وتعالى understand for
‏se الله سبحانه
وتالى
mercy he seek
forgiveness however the
disbeliever the
delusion
the he
sees as
being
conf life ‏that if allah does punish me
immedi for this or that this means that
this or that is okay for me to do
nothing wrong with
it if allah wasn't pleased with my way
of life he would have punished me he
would destroy me why is he letting me
live and continue and allowing me to
flish
if he wasn't other pleased with
‏ex those who are upon destruction who
are just a few a
few sins away from being compl
annihilated and their souls forever
l we have a
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏those who
disb those who are upon destruction mis
those who are sur to be ded by
allah are the ones
ence in
words ‏we have the words of الله we have
action of الله the words of
الله
instru tell الله
des action of
الله are more
ambiguous we are responsible for
upholding the words of allah as for
allah does does not he not سحانه وى we
are not
in
‏ence
words you say for
instance brother why don't you pray why
don't you stop doing this why don't you
doing this the person says well wanted
me to do that he would guide me and make
me الله سبحانه
وتعالى حرام
‏homosexuality is
abomination and people say he does like
why create we
can use that line of
thinking
basically make permiss for
ours
‏us why did he create
ps this is a
very skewed arrant way
of looking at all سبحانه
وتعالى
الله and using his as excuse to do so is
the hmk ‏the people hell exactly exactly
exactly exactly that is methy is
form as we are in position jud الله
سبحانه
وتالى said this over here but you did
this over here so contradicting
yourself this is not the position of
the الله سبحانه
وتالى فعال لما
يرد
ches لا يسال عما يفعل وهم
يسالون ان شاء الله اعلم صلى الله وسلم
على نبينا
محد
[Silence]
ان